[Musique]
bonsoir laurent des bonnets vous êtes en
direct à paris et en situation comme on
dit vraiment en situation est loin des
temps ce soir est ce que l'eau continue
à monter
oui on voit ici de rang nord le niveau
continuer à monter sur ses quais où
d'habitude les parisiens peuvent
circuler jusqu'à ce poteau blanc ce
drapeau la scène a donc gagné au moins
trente mètres de largeur sur chaque rive
et vous le voyez on s'enfonce
extrêmement rapidement il faut être
prudent puisqu'il y a beaucoup de
courant beaucoup d'objets aussi charriés
par le fleuve des bouts de bois des
débris des panneaux de signalisation
emporté d'autres qui sont quasiment
totalement submergé comme ici cette
entrée d'un parking un parking qui est
totalement invisible ce soir les
péniches autour de moi ont toutes été
évacuées vous le voyez derrière moi les
ponts sur la seine paraissent désormais
très bas toute navigation et ce soir
impossible sur l'a5 merci laurent
[Musique]